[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui nous nous trouvons
au cirque de cilaos au lieu du
marronnage le terme de marronnage
désigne un phénomène très particulier la
fidh des esclaves dans les montagnes ou
par la mer afin d'échapper à la
servitude maîtres subi dans les
habitations en l'absence de traces du
marronnage la mémoire s'est conservée
par les noms des lieux etc par les
esclaves malgaches dans les terres
intérieures teulier cilaos mafate et
saladier cet acte de l'existence à l'
esclavage fut une réalité historique
d'envergure à belle île bourbon jusqu'à
l'abolition définitive en 1848 ces
hommes et ces femmes chercher une seule
chose retrouver leur liberté
[Musique]
la vallée secrète est le premier site
archéologique de marronnage avec
halloween elle a été découverte par
hasard par un guide de haute montagne en
1995 la vallée secrète culminent à 2200
mètres d'altitude dans le cirque de
cilaos a connu des documents des
archives et des traditions orales la
vallée secrète abrite un site
exceptionnel
les vestiges se compose à l'ouest d'une
plateforme présentant des ossements de
fun et de deux structures bâties
[Musique]
le repas des marrons était en grande
partie composé de viande d'oiseaux jury
ni incapable de voler le pétrel de barau
complétée par celle de petits porcs
sauvages et de chèvres
la nouvelle r29 alors oui satisfait
lorsque les camps de marrons sont
attaqués par les chasseurs du noir le
plus souvent les femmes sont capturés
car elle représente une source
importante pour les colons sur la
composition des camps l'existence
d'autres camps alors que les hommes sont
bien souvent tués on leur coupe la main
droite ou la tête comme preuve après
avoir reçu le baptême et sa soeur de
noix touche alors une prime les mains et
être coupés sont ensuite attachés aux
lieux à kuching en guise d'avertissement
et de dissuasion pour les esclaves qui
pensent à s'enfuir sud de la plantation
m
il faudra retenir que l'histoire a fait
du marronnage de la quête de la liberté
une affaire est essentiellement
masculine comme la colonisation dans les
récits et les documents des archives est
entré au marronnage il ne fait aucun
doute que les femmes esclaves sont
source de motivation à la reconquête de
la liberté elle incite prépare et aide
les esclaves à s'enfuir de plantation
elle participe ainsi à la surveillance
des cultures des croyances des pratiques
religieuses et des rites de la terre
natale esclaves m ou marron ses
personnages de l'histoire se mélangent
et se confondent dans les mythes le
marronnage est certes une quête pour la
liberté mais aussi et avant tout une
véritable histoire d'amour des hommes
noirs pour leurs familles
[Musique]
elle ne joue pas le même rôle qui va
selon jm macro leaf mais rien n'aurait
été la compagne d'un grand chef marron
noomi fanga dont le camp se trouve à
cilaos elle a été tuée par le chasseur
de noir edward roberts dans un document
d'archivés datant de 1750 et chasseurs
de noir françois mainsard sur ariane la
bien aimée du chef ma fac à la rivière
des galets ainsi mafate aurait eu pour
compagne une certaine rahard yann mafate
marron d'origine malgache était un
puissant sorcier
[Musique]
et encore le tueur année encore le
minutes immunitaire